[Music]
don't you love that music 50 years ago
this week 2001 a Space Odyssey captured
the nation's imagination with a
scientifically accurate vision of space
travel
now a new Smithsonian's ibut celebrating
the anniversary aims to make visitors
think about our place in the universe
a replica of the hotel rooms seen at the
end of the movie will open this weekend
at the National Air and Space Museum in
Washington DC Kris Van Cleave is there
for a look you'll see first on CBS this
morning when we last saw Kris he was
laying on a bed Kris good morning good
morning Gail I got out of bed and I can
tell you 50 years ago the movie had a
premiere here in Washington DC at the
Uptown Theater not far from the museum
we got a sneak peek at the exhibit and I
can tell you it's not going to help you
understand the ending any better than
you already do but they're hoping it
makes you think about space travel and
things beyond before the world watched
live as Neil Armstrong took that one
small step director Stanley Kubrick and
writer arthur c clarke captured the
nation's imagination with their
groundbreaking film 2001 a space odyssey
a mission to Jupiter exposed the cast to
possibilities of extraterrestrial life
and the ship's artificial intelligence
computer Hal 9000 gone rogue while it
earned mixed reviews the film gained a
cult following even if the ending left
many baffled when you walked in here the
first time what struck you one of the
things is the character of the lighting
in the room it is a reflects a a
approach that Kubrick took to usually
build in the lighting into the sets
themselves
Martin Collins is the curator of the
Smithsonian's Air and Space Museum
exhibit celebrating the film's fiftieth
anniversary it includes this recreation
of the iconic hotel room from the scene
intended to make you think are we alone
in the universe and if we encounter
extraterrestrial life how might that
experience changes as well
a new book from author Michael Benson
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of CBS looks at the four year production
of the film
we're still talking about 2001 50 years
later because for one thing the film
deals with four million years of human
evolution Benson says the movie sparked
the rise of science fiction in Hollywood
the human characters in 2001 seemed
semi-automated in robotic and the only
real human character was how and this
was definitely Kubrick's intention to
raise these kinds of questions
this is arthur c clarke a year after
2001 a space odyssey became a
blockbuster arthur c clarke appeared on
CBS news alongside walter cronkite to
cover the launch of Apollo 11 I didn't
imagine it would be in my lifetime
Clarke whose collection of works is now
archived at the Smithsonian said he was
already thinking about travel to Mars
and beyond
I'm excited yet it's familiar there's a
feeling of familiarity about all this
and now of course I thinking about the
next thing but Cronkite wanted an answer
to the question on everyone's mind
asking Clarke to explain the ending of
the movie would you like to tell me what
that's all about I didn't really get the
ending I'll be honest with you but the
debate about the ending is still going
fifty years later the exhibit is set to
open this weekend to the public it is
free but if you don't want to wait in
line you will need a time to ticket John
all right Kris Van Cleave for us thank
you
that's why you write an ending like that
so they're still talking about it 50
years later even if you don't know